Narrator: This jagged sheet of rock
is hanging 200 feet above a walking trail
next to the Niagara River.
It's already loose, and if it falls,
it could mean serious injury
to hikers on the path below.
That's where the rope
access team comes in.
If they do their job just right,
most of Niagara Falls' 9
million yearly visitors
will never even know they were here.
Andy: First jump of the day.
Andy: Am I scared?
Crew member: Yeah.
Andy: Am I scared?!
Crew member: You should be.
Andy: I have a healthy
respect. That's all.
Narrator: This cliff is located
at Devil's Hole State Park,
roughly 4 miles north of Niagara Falls.
Team members like Andy and
Christian will scale the cliff
and maintain the crew's gear.
Later, Jake will clear
dislodged rocks from the trail.
If those rocks were to fall naturally,
there's nothing stopping them from coming
and just plowing through
somebody that's on the trail.
So very necessary work, what we do here,
and you can see here all the rocks
that come down there are pretty sizable,
and they could cause some damage.
Narrator: It's a dangerous job.
Dehydration, injury, and inclement weather
are just some of the risks.
Thunderstorms are forecast today,
so the team is on high alert
for signs of lightning,
which would endanger the crew.
Andy: We won't work in
lightning. That's about it.
We're going to have fun.
You know, usually when
we show this to people,
they say they didn't
even know this existed.
Narrator: There are 12
members of today's crew:
four supervisors, including
Andy, and eight technicians.
Today, their goal is to clear
this entire section of the cliff.
Their day begins at 7 a.m.
at the maintenance shop,
where the team packs a
variety of gear into vehicles
to take it to the access
point above the trail.
Andy: See, the fun thing about this
is that I don't actually
jump with them every day.
So today will be one of
the days I jump with them,
which is good because I've been
wanting to do this for a while.
These are the guys who
do it every single day,
and they're really, really good at it.
Narrator: After a short 10-minute drive,
the team arrives at the access
point and begins gearing up.
Christian: I guess we could start with
the pièce de résistance.
This is our climbing harness.
It's a Class III harness,
and it's called that because
of the shoulder straps.
Narrator: The shoulder
straps prevent climbers
from slipping out of the harness
if they accidentally turn upside down,
and the seat balances their body weight
so that blood flow to their
legs isn't restricted.
Comfort is also of the utmost importance,
as climbers can be suspended
for more than two hours at a time.
Christian: This device
here is our bar rack.
This is what we use to rappel.
It's a pretty old-school device.
We have a lot of mud and grit,
and when the ropes get wet, they swell.
So there's not a lot of moving
parts; it's all friction.
So that's our descent device.
Andy: All right, pretty
much all ready to go here.
No one cares about me.
Everyone says, "Andy, just
take care of yourself."
[laughing]
So, what they're talking about
is some guys have a rope
handler watching their line,
and then some of us are
on what we call an ASAP,
which is this. This is your backup device.
And so I'm just fully in
control of all of my descent.
So I can actually step over the edge now.
First jump of the day.
Andy: Am I scared?
Crew member: Yeah.
Andy: Am I scared?!
Crew member: You should be.
Andy: I have a healthy
respect. That's all.
The crew's really close.
You know, we joke around a lot,
but when it is time to
actually go over the edge
and do work, we kind
of call that game time,
because it is. You know, you
need to take it seriously
because there's a lot of risks involved.
This program that we're a part of
has been going on since about the 1930s,
and about the whole time
they've been using pike poles.
There's a lot of utility with this.
This is made out of solid fiberglass here.
So if it gets into the cliff,
this can flex a lot.
You can use this to position
yourself on the wall,
and then you can use this
to gently remove debris.
You can grab stuff with the
hook, gently pull it out.
It can fit into cracks,
and then you can get leverage that way.
Narrator: One of the things that makes
removing these rocks
especially challenging
is that these cliffs undergo
something called differential erosion,
which means that areas of the cliff erode
at different rates.
Layers of shale rock located
lower on the cliffside
wear away more quickly
than the layer of
dolomite rock at the top.
That leaves large unstable chunks of rock,
sometimes the size of an SUV,
hanging at the cliff's edge.
The crew uses a controlled swing
to gain access to material
beneath overhangs.
To do this, they push
themselves away from the wall
with their feet to maintain
that controlled movement.
These are softball shin pads,
and they work really,
really well for what we do.
You try not to knee the wall,
but sometimes for stability
purposes, you know,
you can't really help it.
We all try to wear steel toe
or some sort of composite toe.
Rocks are hard.
You know, you can't always
dodge a rock when you're moving,
so having something like
that to keep yourself safe
is 100% necessary.
So, all the rocks that we're knocking down
are essentially coming right
to the trail and then some,
and they're going right
to the Niagara River,
which we have right there below us.
Narrator: It's 10 a.m.
The crew is only about
two-thirds of the way through their climb
when the one thing they're
worried about happens: a storm.
[thunder striking]
Crew member: Copy. Looks like
we might have a wall of rain.
Cinematographer: Yeah,
I'm going to head back.
Let's head back.
Narrator: The crew hears
thunder and spots lightning
as they're on the cliffside.
They need to stop working immediately.
That will end their progress for today.
Andy: So, today we
actually had to cut short.
We have metal pike poles in our hand.
We got a lot of metal gear on us,
so we just tried to get out of
there as quickly as we could.
Anything that's going to pose
a hazard to the employees,
then we just stop.
Narrator: The crew had only been working
on the 200-foot cliffside
for less than an hour
when the storm began.
On a typical day, it could
take the crew up to three hours
to clear a whole section.
When they're able to resume,
they'll finish removing rocks
from the lower section of the cliff
and then stabilize the slope
side with wire meshing.
This is the primary part of our work here,
that we're going to try
and clear this all out
so we can essentially have an
open hiking trail here again.
And it's going to take a good bit of work
and a good bit of time
to get this cleared out
to be safe for us to open it again.
Narrator: Back at the shop,
the crew does paperwork
and washes their gear.
Andy: There's actually a
lot of paperwork required
with all this stuff,
and then also just
keeping their gear clean.
You can kind of see from my shirt,
I'm filthy from one jump today.
And, you know, if this is how I look,
our gear is even worse.
Christian: So, soapy water helps
break it and lift the dirt.
Using a toothbrush too to get in there,
and then using an air compressor to spray
any of the soap and dirt that's in there.
And then we have a
lubricant too when it's dry
to get in there, and it
prevents rust and corrosion.
Narrator: After the rope access
team has made some progress,
it's time to start clearing the rocks
from the walking paths below.
This is where the gorge crew comes in.
Jake: We take care of
about seven trails in total
within the gorge itself
and then two up top, on topside.
Now we are in the process
of cleaning the trail
and rebuilding it.
We've already come down,
cleared the loose debris off the trail,
and then started staging to get ready
for the bigger jobs ahead.
Narrator: One of those jobs
includes a specialized
stabilization technique
to ensure the slope side is secure.
Jake: So, down here, to fix these trails,
we use gabion baskets.
It's a 6-foot-by-3-foot cube
that is made of wire meshing.
And what you do is you dig them down,
place them within the trail
or wherever you need them,
and then you add rock to the inside
so that the rock weighs it down.
A job like this can take a week or two,
but if we have a good day
where we're really rocking
and getting stuff done,
it can be a maybe three- to four-day job.
Christian: This mound right
here, if all hands are on deck,
I'd like to see, hopefully
by the end of the summer
we get a majority of it taken out
and then we have put in some
stabilization techniques
to help build the trail back up.
So I could definitely see
us working into the fall,
and if I had to make a guess,
it'll probably be open next summer.
Andy: I think if you're going
to do this kind of work,
at the core, you have to
enjoy working outdoors.
You get to see special
things that people don't see,
plants and animals, the landscape.
The work that you do, it's really hard,
but then you're helping
keep the park safe.
You make a meaningful difference.
If you're just a park user,
you might not even realize
we were ever there,
and that's kind of the point.